What I have for you today is going to come
as a huge shock to some people.
It certainly shocked me.
I found out this weekend about what is possibly
the longest running con played on the David
Pakman show, uh, in, in the show history of
the show.
Over the years we've received voicemails that
have sort of stood out.
We had, for example, Turkey burger lady who
left a voicemail, which has become a cult
favorite with completely no context leaving
me a recipe, a very detailed recipe for how
to make a good Turkey burger.
Here's a sample of that voicemail.
Do you love Turkey burgers?
But you're never quite sure how to make them
well now I can tell you how to do it.
It's easy.
First just top the burger with one slice of
cheese and eat it until the cheese melts.
I'm assuming you've already made the Turkey
burger part, then what you're going to want
to do is spread some Manet's on cuts by the
rolls.
Okay.
Very good one.
Another time we had an Irish version of Jordan
Peterson call, I call it that.
It was Jordan Peterson with a slightly too
Irish sounding accent.
The clip, very popular.
Warning me about Joe Rogan.
Take a listen to that one.
Oh, hi David.
This is Jordan B. Peterson calling in, uh,
you know, just to call it because say you
heard the exciting news that you might be
on the tool Rogan podcast leader this week.
So, uh, congratulations on that.
And uh, just wanted to call and also see,
uh, make sure you study up before you go on
there because I did it myself and um, I didn't
have all my ideas and [inaudible] who here
is in my head.
That was another interesting voicemail that
a lot of people like.
Then we had, how could we forget the source
audio for the David Pakman show?
Dubstep remix contest, which was all spurred
by this song that was left on our voicemail
one day.
So David Pakman show, it's my favorite show.
You do more good dive, you know the Gerber
pack
that led to like a dozen or more remixes in
an entire other contest that we did.
Now over the weekend, I was contacted by someone
claiming that they did all of those voices
and many more.
Their name is Simon when held, and I admit
I was skeptical because these are all over
the place.
Could one person really be doing all of these
over a period of years?
And I never noticed.
So I asked Simon, I need you to send me a
single recording where you do all of these
different voices or a bunch of them and he
did Turkey, burger lady and all take a listen
to this.
Hi David.
This is Trish Nelson, but Turkey burger lady.
Did you end up cooking a Turkey burger?
How to turn out.
I just want you all to know I'm developing
a cooking show called, it's not my diet, but
I just had to try it today.
We're going to cook a special French delicacy.
You may have heard of it.
Chris songs, our celebrity guests, our former
president, William Jefferson Clinton and Arnold
shorts, n****r say hi y'all.
Hey David.
This is bill Clinton as ever.
Big fan of your show.
Y'all do great work.
Keep it up.
David, this is Arnold Schwartzenegger, former
governor of California.
I just want to remind you to watch my classic
movie kindergarten cop.
It's great.
I break a pencil with my thumb.
It would help you to learn to be less of a
girly man.
[inaudible] just silly.
We invited cause I pseudo intellectual Jordan
Peterson, but he's too busy on his next book.
12 more rules for life.
He sure is a stickler for roles, at least
when it comes to live.
I'm writing a third book to even more 12 rules
for life.
It's absurd.
Sure.
Where did you come from?
Go away.
Today's show is booked.
Our last guest, it's a young man named Simon
who wants to share a song.
Hit it, Simon.
Okay.
The David Pakman.
It's my favorite show.
You do Dan.
You know it's electron seated.
I say no, the day pack [inaudible] well, that
song was very interesting.
Okay.
This is Trish Nelson of, it's not my diet,
but I just had to try it.
Signing out.
Yeah.
So anyway, really amazing stuff.
Great work.
There are a bunch of other callers that Simon
has done over the years.
Fake Ted Cruz and a whole bunch of others.
It was one person all along now, because people
will ask, this has nothing to do with Troy
York.
Troy York is an actual right wing antagonist
that calls in with racist characters, like
a black character named Jamal Jenkins, a Hispanic
character called Ramon Remos.
That's how he pronounces it.
None of those Troy York characters have anything
to do with Simon.
I don't want Simon pulled into that.
You can check out Simon's work on Instagram
at Simon underscore, Morris underscore when
held really, really great stuff.
And it turns out that, uh, it was, it was
a con job all along a nice job, Simon.
Very, very nice.